Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Hallo! Hallo.
Wie geht's?
Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO mit mir, Stefan.
Wir sind auf einem Frostplaneten gelandet heute, hier ist alles kalt und man kann den
Atem sehen.
Das war das fantastische Intro von Wolli.
Vielen Dank an ihn für die Wolli. Wolli? Wolli. Moment. Wolli. Er selbst hat seine M3-Datei als Wolli, also als Interpreten Wolli genannt, aber er hat sich als Walli vorgestellt. Wir haben schon Widersprüche erkannt. Und mit dir, Führung und den Wild, du bist auch am Start. Du willst dir dich selber vorstellen, ist okay, weil du mittlerweile auf deinem Elfenbeinturm du willst erkannt werden.
Waldi? Waldi. Waldi, Waldi.
Ob Waldi auch mal Waldi, also von
engen Freunden, von so richtig guten Anhängern,
ob mal Waldi genannt wurde? Ich glaube schon.
Ja. Jetzt gibt es ja den neuen
Film mit Grindelwald, ist das Waldi?
Grindel und Waldi. Ist das Waldi mal? Ne,
Grindelwald ist ein anderer Böserwicht.
Achso, ich habe ein bisschen Überblick verloren.
Ralph Fiennes ist Waldi, Tony Depp
ist Grindi. Ja.
Ich bin gerade so im T-Modus, ich habe mir das irgendwie
Die Kündelwald ist ein anderer Bösewicht. Ach so, ich hab von welchen Überblick verloren. Ralph Fiennes ist Voldy, Tony Depp ist Grindy. Ja, ich bin gerade so im T-Modus, ich habe mir das irgendwie, ich weiß, ich ziehe jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen die Live-Show nach in Hamburg. Wir können ein bisschen nachziehen. Wir haben über die verrücktesten Dinge gesprochen, über nordkoreanische Konzentrationslager, überhaupt keine Reaktion im Publikum, sobald ich den Begriff Bananentee entspreche. Ja, die Leute sind auch geflippt. Die Leute sind ausgeflippt. Eruption, Fragenrufe, Fragen. Leute haben den Saal verlassen, es war intensiv. Und ich bin mittlerweile so im Teemodus, dass ich mittlerweile aus allem Tee machen will. Heute dachte ich mir zum Beispiel, Käsetee, du haust einfach so einen schönen geriebenen Emmentaler in so einen Teebeutel in heißes Wasser. Kann das funktionieren? Wo sind die Grenzen für Tee? Ich glaube, es hat Grenzen. Wobei, ich bin mir nicht sicher. Angenommen, also das Beispiel. Es gibt ja Christina Tosi, die Pastry, The Pastry Chef von Netflix. Die verkauft ja in New York Cornflakes-Milch, also so Cereal Milk. Heisst, sie lässt einmal Milch im Tee-Prinzip oder Kaffeeprinzip durch eine Schüssel Cornflakes wandern, weil sie sagt, die Milch am Ende ist doch am geilsten. Wenn du die Cornflakes gegessen hast und dann die Milch die isst, dann ist das am besten. Das ist eine geniale Idee. So, und dann verkauft die quasi Kakao mit der Milch, mit der Cereal Milch. und die backt auch Kuchen mit der Cereal-Milch. Die macht Sahne und Eis, Soft-Eis, mit dieser Cereal-Milch. Weil Milch ist ja dann, mit Milch kann es ja weiterarbeiten. Mit Milch kann es ja was anfangen. Alter, du, das ist Next Level Milch. Ja, genau. Das ist Next Level Milch. Vor allem irgendwo bei ihr zu Hause muss ja dann eine, sag ich mal, Schüssel Cornflakes stehen, die maximal keinen Geschmack mehr hat, durch die so viel Milch durchgepresst wurde, weil selbst wenn du Cornflakes Milch hast, sind die Cornflakes ja immer noch gut. Ja. Ist ja nicht so, dass du die Cornflakes isst und die haben überhaupt keinen Geschmack mehr, dann denkst du dir, Moment, wo ist denn jetzt der ganze Geschmack hingekommen? Und dann siehst du, ah, wo da unten das ist. Doppelverwertung. Nee, du kannst die auch noch essen.
Verständlich wird sich der Geschmack nicht eigentlich.
Ist das nicht einfach eine Verdoppelung?
Nee.
Oder ist in dem Konflikts einfach so viel Zucker drin,
dass selbst die Hälfte davon noch völlig ausreichend ist?
Nee, du sprichst gerade von so einer Art Perpetuum mobile,
was so aus sich selber Energie erschafft.
Perpetuum Messily.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Nein? Hat das mal jemand getestet?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob Perpetuum Frosties funktioniert. Bin mir nicht sicher. Wow, aber irgendwo müssen diese Cornflakes rumliegen, die so richtig lächelig sind. Ja, die will ich. Die will ich eigentlich. Die Milch ist doch uncool. Du willst ja nicht, also man sagt, du bist 80% in die absolut richtige Richtung gegangen. Niemand von uns wäre jemals in diese Richtung gegangen, Aber dann bist du falsch abgebogen. Weil dann hätte ich gerne, ich hätte gerne das, was übergeblieben ist. Vor allem jedes isolierte Teil von Cornflakes ist besser als Cornflakes selbst. Die Milch alleine ist besser und die laschen Cornflakes alleine sind auch besser. Ja, vielleicht war dieser Zeitraum, in dem wir Cornflakes gegessen haben, nur so eine nervige Überbrückungszeit, bis wir zu einer besseren Idee kommen. Das ist wie so eine Beziehung, die nicht abgebrochen wird, wo man einfach merkt, ihr gehört nicht zusammen. Ihr habt euch ausgesaugt, aber ihr habt nichts mehr zu gewinnen. Ihr könnt jetzt nur noch getrennt besser werden. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich hatte immer ein komisches Gefühl beim Essen von Kornflecks. Ich hatte immer so ein Gefühl, ja, es ist gut, aber irgendwas ist das schon am Ziel. Es fühlt sich falsch an. Es fühlt sich einfach nicht richtig an. Nee, da war was falsch. Und ich finde, das ist so der neue Step. Du machst es entweder für Milch, du hast wie am Teebeutel genuckelt. Es fühlt sich auch nicht gut an, wenn du den Teebeutel im Mund steckst. Oder gegessen teilweise. Genau, so hat sich das angefühlt für mich, Cornflakes zu essen. Das war dieser nervige Zwischenschritt, bis jemand auf die Kommission ist, ah, ins Wasser halten, ah, Milch daraus machen. Ja, das ist genial, die Cornflakes mir verkaufen. Ich dachte ja ursprünglich, es gibt ja auch dann so Drinks, so Snickers-Drinks oder so, da dachte ich auch, das wäre das. Aber es ist was ganz anderes. Man hat Snickers in Milch gelegt. Snickers-Tee. Vor allem, du kannst ja Tee noch mal komplett weiterdenken, wenn du es nicht mit Wasser denkst, sondern mit Milch. Jetzt zum Beispiel Käse-Tee. Oder Marte. Aber denk mal Käse-Tee in Milch. Dann hast du eine feine Käsesosse. So, und dann kommst du nämlich in den Bereich Herber-Tee. Dann kommst du im Bereich Fondue. G glaube ich sogar. Da geht es dann auch knapp an der Illegalität vorbei, aber du bist
bei Fondue abgebogen. Du bist bei Fondue
rechts abgebogen. Fondue ist
doch auch nichts anderes als
Fondue ist Tee andersrum.
Nee, Fondue hat mehrere
Metaebenen. Fondue hat zum einen
statt Wasser, also angenommen,
okay, okay, Florentin, angenommen
Fondue ist Tee, dann ist in diesem Beispiel der Käse, der flüssige, genau, ist das Wasser, nee, ist der Tee. Fondue ist Anti-Tee, weil das Gute ist im Flüssigen. Aber was ist denn das Fleisch, was du in dem Fondue garst? Das Wasser. Nein, der Beutel natürlich. Ich würde es andersrum sehen. Ich würde sagen, Fondue ist Anti-Tee, wo das Gute das Flüssige ist und das Feste durch das Flüssige aufgewertet wird. Was ist der Teebeutel bei deinem Fondue? Wasser. Weil beim Tee wird ja das Flüssige durch das Feste aufgewertet, Wasser wird aufgewertet durch die Teepflanze und beim Fondue wird das Feste durch das Flüssige aufgewertet. Du trinkst danach nicht den Fondue-Topfleer und sagst, boah, das hat jetzt aber einen tollen, wohligen Fleischgeschmack.
Genau, das wäre wiederum Fleischtee, wenn du Tee in der Fleischkäse aufkochen würdest.
Fondue ist Fleischkäsetee.
Ja, wenn du es umdrehst. Antifleischkäsetee.
Ja, weil du nur den Beutel danach isst. Habe ich schon verstanden. Wir kriegen wieder mehrere Mails, ich habe den Beutel gegessen. Wir können direkt in die Rubrik. Die Entschuldigung. Sorry. Sorry. Also, ja, wir haben einiges aufzuwickeln heute. In der vorletzten Folge behauptet Flo, sitzt die Flo vor mir und sagt mir Serienguru, dass die Sopranos, ist ja einfach eine No-Bullshit-Serie. Da ist ja, es wird einfach die ganze Linie erzählt. Ich verdiene das. Da gibt es keine Flashbacks, da gibt es keine Traumsequenzen, gar nichts. Einfach no bullshit von vorne bis hinten. Ich hab alle Folgen 80-mal gesehen. Ich bin kurz gegen den Stecker gekommen. Ist es noch drin? Ja, ist gut. Ich bin alle Folgen 80-mal geguckt, ich kenn mich da aus. Nein, stellt sich raus, es gibt ganze Folgen, die Traumsequenzen sind. Ja. Womöglich haben alle Serien, die es heute machen, abgeschaut von Sopranos. Die Sopranos sind schuld daran. Also erstens möchte ich dazu sagen, dass diese Flashbacks und Träume erst in den späteren sind. Erst sagst du sorry? Erst sag ich, es tut mir leid. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Also erstens möchte ich sagen, dass sie erst in der späteren Entwicklung kommen und dass sie immer was Besonderes sind und kein durchgängiges Stilmittel. Das ist nicht die Rechtfertigungsrubrik. Ja, ihr habt recht, ich habe Unrecht, ja, ihr habt recht. Aber auch noch eine Sache, ich weiß nicht, ob du es gehört hast, und zwar wir haben darüber gesprochen, Elektroautos, Elektroflitzer werden in der Zukunft immer ein grösseres Thema. Und wir haben darüber gesprochen, welche Geräusche die machen können. Hast du das Video gesehen von diesem Pizzalieferdienst? Nein. Ja, ich habe kein Internet hier. Gut. Und zwar gibt es, glaube ich, irgendwie Pizza.de oder irgendwie so einen Pizzalieferanten, Pizzarando, die... Dominos. Oh, Dominos, das kann gut sein. Ja, genau, die nämlich ihre Pizzenausfahren auf Elektrorollern und die aber ein Fahrgeräusch gemacht haben, extra für ihre Auslieferroller. Und das kannst du dir jetzt mal anhören, Stefan. Ich hoffe, du findest das Richtige. Wir werden es hier auch einspielen oder stümperhaft, amateurhaft über unsere Mikrofone hier aufzeichnen. Dominos Pizza Safe Sound. Jetzt, ne, warte, kurz, kurz. Dürftet ihr es hören? Ich war noch verbunden mit meinen 380 Euro QC 35 Bose QuietComfort Noise Cancelling Kopfhörern. Und hier kommt der Sound.
Bei Amazon.
Das ist das Geräusch. Dominos, Peter, er fährt durch die Welt. Der Typ ist die ganze Zeit genervt auf seinem Roller.
Ist tatsächlich Dominos und ist anscheinend niederländische Dominos, wo die Roller diese Geräusche machen.
Aber es ist genau das, was wir gesagt haben. Unser Beispiel war Fiat, Fiat, Fiat, Fiat.
Es ist exakt das. Dominos, Dominos, Dominos, Dominos, Dominos, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker.
Also falls ihr euch fragt, warum die Lieferleute immer so fucking genervt sind, wenn sie mal hier ankommen, dann weil sie den ganzen Tag hören. Lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega, lega kann nicht länger als eine Minute sein. Aber haben da Wissenschaftler herausgefunden, okay, das ist der nervigste Ton der Zeit. Nee genau, eher so, da ist man dann wirklich aufmerksamer oder ist es eher so ein, ja, wir machen einfach irgendein Geräusch und das ist wie eine Art Werbung.
Und warum ist es dann nicht einfach, keine Ahnung, wir haben heute im Angebot, heute ist Pizzatag und deswegen sind alle Pizzen billiger. Warum machen die dann sowas? Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden. Dominos, Dominos, Dominos, Dominos. Läger, läger, läger, läger, läger. Weißt du, vor allem, ich habe das Gefühl, so jede Industrie jede Technologie hat sich extrem weiterentwickelt. Also irgendwie die Textilkunstindustrie, die Metallkunst. Die Textilkunstindustrie? Ja, halt so wie Textilien hergestellt werden. Da kennst du dich aus. Und ich finde aber, die einzige Industrie, die sich nicht wirklich weiterentwickeln zu scheinen, ist die Werbeindustrie. Ja, sogar zurückentwickeln. Die einfach jetzt auf die Idee kommen. Ja, wir sagen einfach ganz oft den Namen unserer Firma, oder? Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, das ist doch eine gute Idee, oder? Ja, stimmt. Ich meine, man kann sowas wie Werbung auch studieren. Wo ist? Nein, ins Wiccan Feeling, wo ist das? Mit Sotzahne-Joghurt, weißt du, das war hauptsächlich Musik, das war die Phase, als man gesagt hat, Menschen mögen Musik, Menschen mögen Erdbeer-Joghurt, easy, aber heute, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, Dominus, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst, Wurst. Aber, gibt zu, ihr wollt jetzt ein kleines Würstchen. Ich hab Bock auf einen Zotja-Sahnejoghurt, um echt zu sein. Ich meine, letztlich ist Wurstwasser eigentlich auch Wursttee.
Du kannst Wurstwasser auch herstellen.
Okay, wir kommen da nicht wieder raus.
Du bist in der Tee-Phase.
Ich bin komplett in der Tee-Phase.
Bist du auch so ein Phasentyp?
Ja, total. Mittlerweile schon.
Mittlerweile schon, oder?
Ja.
Ist ansteckend, aber ist gut.
Das ist sowieso, ich habe auch immer gesagt, ich will keinen Job, wo ich mein Leben lang das Gleiche mache, sondern ich will gerne so einen Phasenjob, so einen Projektenjob.
Ja. Und Phasen sind immer besser. Da kannst du sofort, wenn du keinen Bock mehr hast, andere Phase. Mach deine T-Phase, solange du Bock hast. Ich unterstütze dich dabei. Ich glaube, der beste Job, um diese Phasen erleben zu machen, ist eigentlich Schauspieler. Dass du dich für eine Drehzeit einfach als Arzt dann auch wirklich mit den Arztlachen beschäftigst und dann was über den menschlichen Körper lernst. Ja, Frage. Gut, Frage aus einem zugegebenermaßen sehr engen Betrachtungsraum. Schauspieler setzen sich ja nicht wirklich mit der Rolle auseinander. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Der Drehbuchautor hingegen muss es ja, weil Texte müssen ja stimmen, die Geschichte muss ja irgendwo auch stimmen. Aber deswegen, glaube ich, finde ich den Job wirklich am spannendsten, weil du dich zu einem Grad damit auseinandersetzen musst, dass es zwar interessant ist, aber immer noch spannend. Also sobald du richtig reindicken musst in die Materie und es anstrengend wird für dich selber, die Recherche, kannst du auch sagen, okay, es reicht auch, weil für den Zuschauer wird es ja auch anstrengend dann. Deswegen glaube ich, es ist ein sehr angenehmer Job,
um sich auf oberflächlicher Ebene mit Dingen auseinanderzusetzen.
Kennst du dich denn jetzt gut mit den Themen aus, über die du schreibst?
Ja, ich glaube schon, aber auch nur sehr oberflächlich.
Oder dass du dann schreibst Science, Science, Science, Science, Science.
Oh, das hat ja Shonda Rhimes immer gesagt.
Shonda Rhimes, die Showrunnerin von Grace Anatomy zum Beispiel, die hat immer in ihre Drehbücher geschrieben, Medical, Medical, Medical. Gib mir jetzt mal bitte das Medical, Medical, Medical, um auch mal zu zeigen, dass... Stellt, wir brauchen fünf Kilo Medical! Genau, das stand immer in den Drehbüchern, weil, und das zeigt ganz deutlich, dass es darum nicht geht bei der Serie. Es könnte genauso gut im Lehrerzimmer spielen, es könnte genauso gut in einer Gärtnerei spielen, es ist scheißegal, es geht nur um die zwischenmenschlichen Konflikte da. Du meinst also, man könnte Grey's Anatomy, die Drehbücher alle nehmen und umschreiben auf einen Waffelladen. Auf Technical Technical Waffle Waffle Waffle Waffle. Oder Dominos Dominos Dominos. Es wäre eine genauso gute Serie. Nee, natürlich nicht, weil da spielt natürlich vieles da rein. Die Themen, die bei Ärzten eine Rolle spielen, spielen auch in der Serie eine Rolle.
Aber könnte man das nicht gagmässig mal machen, eine Folge Grey's Anatomy einfach umschreiben und alle medizinischen Begriffe umschreiben auf Waffe oder Minigolf. Minigolf und es spielt einfach dann genau die gleichen Storys, genau die gleichen Figuren, aber die sich halt intensiv mit Minigolf einfach auseinandersetzen. Ja.
Ich meine, natürlich, Arzt ist sehr clever gewählt, weil man hat mit dramaturgisch sinnvollen Dingen zu tun, wie Leben und Tod und was heißt es und alte Leute und was heißt es, gutes Leben gehabt zu haben und so weiter. Aber ein guter Sketch bestimmt. SNL hat es mal gemacht mit, die hat Newsroom umgeschrieben auf McDonalds-Filiale. Und es ist wirklich lustig. Das ist eine gute Idee. Newsroom ist dann noch ein bisschen ein Tacken pathetischer und das Ganze,, aber es geht halt um Mac Sunday, ist halt lustig. Das ist eine gute Idee. Die sind gut, da meine ich, bei SNL. Diese ganzen drei buchstabigen Dinge sind alle gut, oder? Sag mal eine Sache, die schlecht ist, gut, RAF. Ja. NPD. Aber ich finde, drei Buchstaben sind, also ich glaube, das könnte man aufstellen, dass drei Buchstaben generell besser sind als vier Buchstaben. NSDAP sind fünf. Scheiße, du hast recht. Wie kannst du so schnell zählen? Weil ich gerade auch darüber nachgedacht habe. Okay, ich sag dir ein Wort und du sagst mir ganz schnell, wie viele Buchstaben es bleibt, okay? Achterbahn. Also keine Superkraft. Hey, es hätte sein ... Erzählt immer noch. Ich bin sehr schlecht im Kopfrechnen, glaube ich. Ja? Pferd. Sechs. Nee. Kanu. Achtzehn. Naja, es hätte sein können, dass wir ein tiefes, verborgenes Talent von Stefan T finden, aber nein. Aber nein, wieder mal eine Enttäuschung. Glaubst du, du hast in dir schon mal eine Superkraft, von der du nichts weißt? Manchmal denke ich, es ist ja letztens so ein Gesellschaftsspiel gespielt bei Almost Playley, bei Rockyman TV, schaut euch an, und ich war extrem gut in dem Spiel. Ich habe es davor noch nie gespielt. Was war es für ein Spiel? Das war ein H.P. Lovecraft-Spiel. Aber schon so Karten. Ein Skill-Spiel oder ein Skill- und Glück-Spiel? Ja, ein bisschen schon, glaube ich, aber viel Glück auch. Wo man so Karten zielt, dann muss man die richtigen Karten legen. So, und ich war extrem gut im Spiel. Ich habe sofort gewonnen. Und ich dachte mir, wow, vielleicht bin ich der beste Spieler derer der welt in diesem gesellschaft spiel aber wie tragisch das also einerseits gut endlich zu finden worin man tragisch dass das dann nicht das fußball der welt ist ja genau weil ich meine ich kann jetzt immer noch denken ich vielleicht bin ich der beste obo und spieler der welt ich habe in meinem leben noch nie eine bohr in der hand ich weiß nicht mal genau wie viele buchstaben obo hat und vielleicht kann es sein es sein, dass sobald ich die in meiner Hand habe, ich wirklich virtuos dahinflöte und dann alle sagen, wow. Es war nicht so weit weg von Oboe, das Geräusch. Stimmt, ja. Vielleicht bin ich auch der beste Oboen mit dem Mundimitierer der Welt. Was auch ein zweifelhaftes Talent ist, aber ich glaube, gibt es genug Talente für alle neun Milliarden oder sieben Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt? Ich weiß es nicht. Könnte man sich genug Aktivitäten vorstellen? Auch das finde ich gerade einen sehr lustigen Sketch, dass jemand sehr gut in einem Spiel ist, von dem er nicht weiß, dass es in einer anderen Welt, in einem anderen Universum ein Riesending ist. Das ist deren Fussball. Dein scheiß H.P. Lovecraft-Spiel ist in Taiwan irgendwie Millionenbeträge. Und die Manager kloppen sich um dich und du bist nur in den besten Hotels, weil du einfach gut darin bist, HB Lovecraft-Spiele zu spielen. Aber das ist halt oft so bei Sportlern. Es gibt halt irgendwie so Sportarten, die oft nur in zwei Ländern wahnsinnig beliebt sind. Ich sag jetzt mal sowas wie Rugby. Ja genau, Cricket ist England und Indien. Ja gut, aber das hängt... Ja, aber stell dir mal vor, du bist ein Engländer, trainierst dein ganzes Leben Cricket und dann sagst du, okay, ich habe Cricket irgendwie Premier League, Cricket League und dann so, ah, du wirst abgeworben vom drittbesten Verein der Welt, ist halt in Indien.
Und dann lebst du halt deinen Rest des Lebens in Indien, was halt wahnsinnig weit weg ist und ganz andere Kultur ist.
Also du kannst entweder in deiner Heimat spielen oder wo ganz woanders.
Ich wollte kurz...
Wo in Gegenfußball...
Das ist eines der wenigen Oboen-Konzerte, die es gibt. Okay, wo kommt das denn jetzt her? Von Oboe. Aber kann es nicht sein, von wem ist das geschrieben? Mozart. Und da ist nicht ein Oboen-Spieler mal zu Mozart so, hey, mega geile Stücke für Tavier, super geil, finde ich geil, aber wie wäre es mit... Das war ein Gag, der war ja auch ein gaggiger Typ. Aber jetzt spielt die Oboe schon keine Rolle mehr, keine grosse, muss man sagen. Aber vielleicht war es einfach so ein Mittelfinger an die klassische Welt, als wir alle gesagt haben, die Oboe ist doch kein echtes Instrument und Mozart, ja hier, Challenge accepted. Und vor allem, er hat ja kein zweites geschrieben und danach so, ja okay, schon ein bisschen recht. Aber bei dem Stück, ich ich habe das so oft ein Orbum von, und du kannst es schlecht pfeifen. Die Oboe ist kein gutes Pfeifeninstrument. Es ist eher ein Element eigentlich. Aber ich habe es mittlerweile, passt drauf, Achtung. Das ist es. Wow. Und ich glaube, das sind wirklich viele Spaziergänge um den Aachener Weiher herum, sonntags, mit so einem G-Rock. Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt sehr viele Leute für klassische Musik inspiriert. Ist aber, glaube ich, auch ein Problem, wenn dir ein Instrument gefällt, aber alle Lieder, die man auf dem Instrument spielt, dir nicht gefallen. Also du bist jetzt irgendwie ein großer Cello-Fan, aber die Lieder, die extra für Cello geschrieben sind, die gefallen hier nicht. Wonder Woman Theme. Du kennst Max nur das Wonder Woman Theme. Und dann auch bis am Ende und dann so, so, das war's. Ich habe alles gespielt, was ich spielen will. So geht es mir ein bisschen bei einer Trompete, die ich mir gekauft habe. Ich kann mittlerweile... Du willst nur Wonderwall. Das kann ich spielen. Und jetzt ist mir das Instrument scheißegal. Ich habe mir einen Ständler gekauft, dass es gut aussieht, wenn es in meinem Wohnzimmer steht. Ja, das ist wichtig. Das ist wichtig. Du willst nicht, dass es einfach so liegt. Nee, es soll nicht liegen,
es soll da stehen. Es soll da stehen und verstauben.
Es soll nicht im gesicherten Koffer liegen.
Nee, vor allem... Kann jemand
von euch mal, der Trompete spielt,
bitte auf eine schöne Studentenparty gehen
und so in dieser Ausklingphase,
wo man normalerweise seine Gitarre rausholen würde,
er würde einfach mal sehen,
hey, hat jemand Bock auf Wonderwall? Ja!
Und dann einfach mit so einer Konzerttrompete Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop du sehr tief spielst. Sehr tief, aber stimmt gar nicht. Das lauteste Instrument im Orchester. Der Kontrabass? Der Kontrabass ist das lauteste Instrument im Orchester. Aber ist es nicht auch leiser, je leiser, je tiefer man ist? Nein. Nein. Für Quatsch, die Wellenlänge ist nur eine andere. Aber du kannst ja mit der gleichen Intensität... äh, rausballern, wie der Wissenschaftler sagt. Aber die Trompete ist auch das Laute. Ich finde Orchester so lustig, alles an Orchestern finde ich lustig, weil alle Instrumente charakterisieren ja Leute. Also niemand auf der ganzen Welt, den du dir vorstellst bei Percussion, ähnelt dem, wie du den ersten Violinisten vorstellst. Niemals sind die austauschbar. Das sind immer so ganz spezielle, man hat einen typischen Mensch im Kopf, wenn man sagt, wenn ich jetzt sage Horn. Oh ja. Wenn ich sage Fagott. Niemand der Fagottisten ist ein Exzentriker. Vor allem, ich denke immer, also wie hoch ist der Übergangsgrad von Schlagzeugern zu Perkussionen im Orchester? Weil viele Jugendliche fangen an mit Schlagzeug. Und viele vielleicht interessieren sich irgendwann für klassische Musik. Aber die Leute, die im Orchester Perkussion spielen, sind nie Schlagzeugerfiguren, sondern immer ganz andere Leute. Meinst du nicht? Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe sehr wenig Wissen darüber. Ich finde finde es vor allem immer interessant, dass manche, also das Orchester ist ja so die Königin, ja, so das Nonplusultra, aber manchmal gibt es dann schon noch Komponisten, die sagen, nee, das reicht mir nicht, da fehlt noch was. Ja, wie Wagner, der gesagt hat, ich hätte gerne neun Hörner. Ja, oder ich hätte gerne jemanden, der auf ein Metallstück schlägt, einfach die ganze Zeit. Oder das ist Oper, das ist noch ein bisschen theatralischer. Aber dann natürlich die Kanone, glaubt Tchaikovsky, einfach eine Kanone dabei. Oder ich find's immer interessant, wenn klassische Komponisten irgendwie so Alltagsgegenstände mit in das Lied mit reinschreiben. Doch, ich find das ein bisschen peinlich. Findest du? Ja, viel, ja, also, klar, Kunst zeichnet sich auch immer durch den Rahmen aus, der gegeben ist. Die Leinwand, keine Ahnung, die Länge eines Musikstückes, in der Popmusik zum Beispiel diese klassischen drei Minuten, von denen man spricht oder sowas, bei Gestücken, die drei Akte, halt sowas. Bedien dich doch einfach der Mittel, die du hast. Und sag dich noch, nee, wisst du was, dieses Ding, was man auf der Chemie kaufen kann, was Kinder hinter sich herziehen, was so raspelt,
das im Orchester wieder einbauen.
Kennt ihr, wenn man so den Reisverschluss
so ganz schnell hoch und runter zieht, kannst du das mal,
leg mal das Fagott weg, scheiß auf, wir sind uns ehrlich,
scheiß mal da auf und mach das mal so im zweiten Teil,
so schnell du kannst einfach, okay?
Okay, geht schon gut.
Aber dann auch immer so, stell dir mal vor also ich glaube, es gibt zum Beispiel dieses eine von Schubert, glaube ich, die Winterreise. Ja, so ganz viele Lieder hintereinander mit Klavier und Gesang. Und dann gibt es aber einmal, wo man in diesem zwei Stunden dauernden Gesang, Gesamtding mit 20 Liedern, muss ja einmal Sänger, auf so eine Hotelrezeptionsklingel hauen, so bling! Die Halligalliklingel. Die Halligalliklingel. Und dann denkt man sich auch immer, wenn dieses Stück aufgeführt werden muss, dann aus dem Musikraum holt man halt den Flügel, ja, und dann, wo ist die Halligalliklingel? Und dann muss man immer diese scheisse Halligalliklingel. Jedes Jahr ist sie weg. Weil irgendwann sich immer einsteckt. Und dann muss wieder einer so ein Halligalli-Spiel zu. Und dann muss man immer diese scheisse Halligalli-Klingel. Weil irgendwann sich immer einsteckt. Und dann muss wieder einer sein Halligalli-Spiel zu Hause mitbringen. Und dann stimmt dann auch die Halli, bevor es losgeht. In B, bitte. In B. Aber vor allem, es gibt nur ein einziges Stück, wo man diese scheisse Halligalli-Klingel braucht. Für keine anderen. Lohnt es sich als Orchester? Hat man sowas dann in der Hinterhand? Es gibt den Oboenraum, es gibt den Streicherraum und es gibt den Verschiedenesraum, wo halt so die ganzen anderen Sachen gelagert werden.
Den Quatschraum, den Schubertraum, die Kanone von Tchaikovsky, einfach so. Den Gong. Der Gong, der gute alte Gong. Ja, lustigerweise, was ich lustig finde, wo ich mich auch frage, warum korrigiert man das nicht, damals waren die Instrumente noch nicht so gut wie heute. Zum Beispiel bei der Zeit, in der Wagner Opern geschrieben hat. Da waren die noch nicht gut.
Deswegen hat er irgendwann gesagt, das Horn soll da präsent sein in dem Stück, beziehungsweise in der ganzen Oper. Deswegen machen wir mal acht Hörner. So. Damals hatten es die Sänger schon schwer, dagegen anzukommen. Bewusste Entscheidung. Mittlerweile wurden aber in der Zeit die Hörner immer besser. Immer besser, immer besser. Mittlerweile wird das Stück immer noch mit acht Hörnern gespielt und die Sänger haben einfach keine Chance, dagegen anzukommen. Also dirigiert Christian Thielemann zum Beispiel immer nie Fortissimo, wenn er Fortissimo dirigieren müsste, sondern immer ein bisschen leiser, weil er sagt, die Sänger haben keine Chance sonst gegen Wagner. Aber warum kann man das nicht? Aber kleinere Hörner haben, so Kinder, so Anfänger haben. Oder einfach alte Hörner nehmen. Aber ist es nicht so, dass die alten, also so eine Stradivari-Violine oder so, total krass ist? Ja genau, ich weiß nicht genau, ich glaube nicht, dass sich das bei jedem Instrument geändert hat. Aber bei den Hörnern zum Beispiel. Also manche Instrumente werden lauter, andere werden leiser. Andere werden schlechter. Und am Ende einfach so, what? Andere werden größer. Merkwürdig. Ja, aber das ist auch so ein Ding, stell dir mal vor, du interessierst dich für Musik und dann der Kontrabass hat dich geballt. Und dann andere laufen so eine Gitarre auf dem Rücken und du hast so einen riesen Kontrabass auf dem Rücken und gehst dann da wieder in den Fussgängerszone immer zum Kontrabassunterricht. Wie nervig. Ich habe letztens ein sehr interessantes Video gesehen von einem Jazzmusiker, der Whiplash analysiert hat. Genau das Video habe ich auch gesehen. Genau, und der hat nämlich auch gesagt, es gibt nämlich in Whiplash eine Szene, wo jemand so einen Kontrabass auf dem Rücken hat. Und dann hat er gesagt, nee, in New York würde man es nicht auf dem Rücken nehmen, sondern immer mit Rollen auf dem Boden fahren. Ja, und das ist genau dieses... Genau das Video habe ich gesehen, deswegen muss ich da sehr drüber lachen, aber bei dem Typen, ich habe es auch noch nie gesehen, dass jemand einen Kontrabass auf dem Rücken hat. Sehr interessantes Video, spannender YouTuber, Adam Neely. Ich glaube, den haben wir echt schon... Den haben wir schon mal gefeatured, ja, featerten immer die gleichen. Toll, toll. Ich glaube, das Orchester wird noch mal verändert. Es gibt ja immer mal wieder so Reformatoren, die dann sagen, hier, jetzt komm, schmeiß den scheiß alten Gong raus oder jetzt, wir brauchen die Violinen. Es gibt immer mal so Petitionen, wo jemand sagt, wir brauchen mehr Fagotte. Sagt wer? Wir wissen nicht, hm? Was? Was? Renn weg, fährt weg. Fagotteululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululul und fahren mit ihrem Fach. Ja, ja. Wie lustig das wäre. Oder einfach, um die Kriminalität einzuschränken, immer der gesamte Name und die Adresse wird genannt, damit es nicht mehr irgendeine Fahrflucht gibt. Stefan Dietze, Meisergasse 4, Stefan Dietze, Meisergasse 4 und dann gibt es keine Fahrflucht mehr. Wie lustig, ich komme morgens immer bei einem DHL-Depot vorbei, wo immer so filmartig, wie Sicario, wie so eine Kolonne, immer morgens fester da vorbei und dann-L-D-L- Und alle Menschen gehen so geduckt mit hochgezogenem Kragen durch die Strassen. Ja, oder das habe ich ehrlich gesagt, man müsste viel mehr Sachen synchronisieren, so dass du zum Beispiel, wenn du so eine, du hast eine Fußgängerzone und da so alle 20 Meter hast du einen Strassenmusiker, dass man einfach mal sagt, Leute, spielt alle dasselbe Stück, so dass du, wenn du von der einen gehst, und dann gehst du immer weiter, einmal durch die Fußgängerzone, dann hast du überall dasselbe Stück. Habe ich nie verstanden, warum nicht Fußgängerzonen beschallt werden mit echter Musik. Weil es unfassbar nervig ist. Oder unfassbar toll ist. Obwohl, in München gibt es zwei U-Bahn-Haltestellen, wo klassische Musik läuft. Odeonsplatz und Universität, beide U-Bahn-Stationen, wo man gesagt hat, ihr seid die Kulturellen, ihr seid die gebildeten Universitäten und unter denen es heißt, scheiß auf die anderen, da wird hingekotzt, wo man will.
Ja, aber hat man herausgefunden, ob das einen Einfluss hat auf die Lebensumstände da?
Vielleicht wollte man einfach klügere Studenten machen.
Oder klügere Obdachlosen.
Das kann sein, ja. Aber Universität ist schon naheliegend, dass man sagt, das sind die Gebildeten.
Auch ein bisschen doof.
Bisschen doof oder ein bisschen platt.
Klassiker ja nicht nur Gebildete, jeder kann Klassiker hören.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Früher hat jeder Schmock
Ja, kannst du schon sagen.
Du kannst ganz
fragen, Schmock kannst du sagen,
Stefan, hau ruhig raus. Das klang gerade falsch.
Und deswegen habe ich kurz gezweifelt.
An meinem Gesicht hast du gesehen, dass ich mich
wohl dabei gefühlt habe, Schmock gesankt zu haben.
Es gibt ja auch so jetzt neu Weihnachtsmarkt,
ganz wichtiges Thema, gerade auch da,
was mich ärgert, ist, dass da immer an jedem Stand, jeder macht seine eigene Weihnachtsmusik und dann ist es immer so durcheinander, wenn die einfach mal so alle gleichzeitig einfach mal Merry Christmas, es ist ein Ross entsprungen, einfach alle und dann kommst du einfach in Weihnachtsstimmung, weil du einfach zugeballert wirst von allen Seiten. Was soll das heißen? Es ist ein Ross entsprungen. Ich glaube, das war damals einfach so, Leute, uns ist ein Pferd weggelaufen. Leute, das ist kein Weihnachtssong, das ist ein Hilferruf. Ach, das ist so besinnlich. Nee, hinterher. Das ist so beruhigend irgendwie. So ein Mensch, der immer so eine sehr sanfte Stimme hat und egal was er sagt. Uns ist ein Ross entsprungen und alle, oh, Weihnachten! Sprungen! Jetzt schön Spekulatius reinpfeffern. Nein, im Ernst, mein Ross ist entsprungen und meine Frau hat eine schwere Verletzung. Ich komme immer so in Stimmung, wenn ich das höre. Toll. Hast du vor, auf Weihnachtsmarkt zu gehen? Schön alleine eine Käsewurst zu drücken? Das muss man wirklich sagen, das Essen auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt ist fantastisch. Ja, lecker. Das ist wirklich, an jedem Stand kannst du, du kannst allein, wenn du am Neumarkt in Köln einmal rumgehst, kannst du bestimmt acht Ständen geil essen. Der originale Raclette-Stand, mega geil, dann gibt es so ein komisches ungarisches Essen, was sowas ist wie so eine fettigere Pizza. Mit Schmand und Fett. Und Italien so, fuck, warum sind wir da nicht draufgekommen? Und alle so, wow, das ist die beste Idee eigentlich aller Zeiten. Dann schön an jedem zweiten Stand einfach mal schön Glühwein reinballern, dann hast du diese Fleisch am Spiess, wo einfach so einen riesen langen Spiess hat, der ist bestimmt so einen halben Meter lang, wo einfach ganz viel Fleisch dran steckt. Was man niemals essen will. Alles ist besser am Spiess. Oh. Bananen am Spiess? Schokobanane am Spiess? Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Schaschlik? Alles eine Banane sagt, du brauchst mich nicht am Spiess. Ich bin eine Art Spiess. Ich bin eine Art essbarer Spiess. Ey, wie wäre es eigentlich, könnte man nicht Bananen so züchten, dass sie schon Schokobananen sind? Wenn man die Schale abmacht, dann eine Schokobanane drunter? Dann eine schöne Schokobananen drunter. Das wäre gut. Und nur Schoko drunter. Oh ja. Also eine Geleebanane, kann man schon Geleebananen züchten? Oder Banane ohne Schale und statt Banane Schoko. Dass du einfach nur so ein Stück Schokolade hast. Das ist der Kindheitstraum, ne? Das wäre gut. So Jaffa-Cakes züchten. Einfach Süßigkeiten züchten. So eine Welt zu leben. Das ist, glaube ich, an die Kinder, wenn sie sich aussuchen könnten, Weltfrieden oder in so einem Land zu wohnen, wo das Gras ist aus Hitchlers Schnüren, das Wasser ist aus Nutella. Alle Kinder würden das vorziehen. Vor allem, jedes Obst wurde ja gezüchtet, dass der gute Teil grösser und der schlechte Teil kleiner wird. Melone, es gibt so alte Gemäldebilder von Melonen, wo der rote Teil ganz klein ist und ganz viel Schale drum und dann hat sich das Verhältnis immer verändert. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir haben bei einem Typ, der ich Melonen malen musste. Es wird wirklich, Leute können diese Ankunft der Götter malen. Und so ein Typ muss nebenan die scheiß Melonen malen. Warum dachte er, bringt das irgendwas? Warum dachte der Typ, so eine Melone, die male ich jetzt. Ja, aber dem haben wir es zu verdanken. Vor allem, es gibt ja auch so Gemälde von so alten Herzögerinnen oder sowas, wo halt die Frau ist halt perfekt gemalt, wirklich so, als würde sie vor dir
stehen. Und dann steht halt daneben so ein
weirder Teddybär und alle so,
was soll das sein?
Und dann, ja, das ist ein Löwe.
Aber der Künstler hat halt noch nie
in seinem Leben einen Löwen gesehen.
Woher denn auch? Der lebt in Deutschland.
Also so.
Und dann hat die Herzogin halt gesagt,
ja, mal mich, easy, kein Problem, ja, und ich hätte gerne einen Löwen. Das ist ein Schmellerling, du hast ein scheiß Schmellerling gemacht. Und der künstler halt so, äh, ein Löwen, okay. Du künstest dem Lexikon nach, wo nur ein Eintrag unter L ist, Liebe, und da war ein Fragezeichen. Unsere verdammtische romantische Epoche. Wir wissen nichts. Dann malt er halt irgendwie so ein krudes Bärchen dahin. Aber dann hat er diesen Lexikon-Eintrag um Löwe erweitert und Teddybär. Das Bild von seinem Teddybären steht bis heute im Lexikon. Und das ist ein falter Funfact. Ich glaube, aber wir haben es bei einem Nahrungsmittel geschafft, zu 100% zu erreichen. Weintraube zum Beispiel, Kerne sind weg. Diese diese Schale ist noch dran. Die kann man auch essen, aber... Genau, Schale zum Beispiel nicht. Aber es gibt eine einzige Sache, die ist zu 100 Prozent, 100 Prozent. Da hast du keine Kerne drin, da hast du keine Schale drumrum, da sind nicht irgendwie so Adern oder so ein Scheiß drin, das ist einfach von unten bis oben 100 Prozent homogen, alles da, nichts muss raus, nichts muss ran, der Kopfsalat. Aber jetzt mal unter uns, was zur Hölle ist eigentlich ein Kopfsalat? Was ist das für eine Art von Pflanze? Also da ist kein Kern drin, da sind keine Samen drin, das ist einfach nur so ein Blätterball, was soll das? Der Blätterball. Ja, aber die Idee von Blättern ist doch, dass sie möglichst viel Oberfläche haben, damit du viel Photosynthese betreibst. Ja, da wurde aber sehr viel manipuliert, da wurde so viel manipuliert, dass die Pflanze, kennst du das Beispiel, diese Hunde, diese Möpse, die mittlerweile nicht mehr atmen können. So fühlt sich diese Pflanze im Extremen. Ach, du meinst, sie war so ganz ausgefeilt? Wenn die Pflanze sprechen könnte,
würde sie sagen,
so langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam,
Töte mich!
Du meinst, sie hat sich im Laufe der
Genmanipulation so in sich zusammengeschrumpelt?
Nee, genau, der Mensch hat die einfach so
zu einem Blätterball gezüchtet.
Das war mal so eine stolze Pflanze.
So ein riesiger Baum vielleicht,
die einfach Stück für Stück eingeführt hat.
Oder so eine Rose, die so offen war.
So eine Blattkrone, wo der Mensch gesagt hat, nee, aber so muss ich das irgendwie...
Das dauert dann ein bisschen doller beim Abwaschen.
Deswegen will ich es gerne als so ein Ball.
Können wir es bitte über tausend Jahre hinweg so züchten, dass es kleiner ist?
Okay, machen wir.
Der Mensch ist eine Bitch.
Können wir diese Kerne komplett wegzüchten, bitte? Die stören. Wenn ich draufkau, muss ich spucken. Ja, okay, dauert halt 700 Jahre. Okay. Nee, ist mir voll okay. Ist mir ganz egal. Hauptsache keine Kerne mehr. Ist mir ganz egal, wie lange das dauert, hauptsache es ist weg. Hauptsache dieser scheiß Kern ist weg. Ach ja. Der hat Geduld, ich glaube, Mensch hat Geduld einfach. Das ist wichtig. Wir müssen kurz ein paar organisatorische Dinge machen. Ich habe nämlich, als ich über meine Steuern gegangen bin, folgende Nachricht aufgefallen, die wir nicht vorgelesen haben. Denn bei Patreon haben wir ja gesagt, Leute können uns Nachrichten schicken, wenn sie eine gewisse Summe bezahlen. Das haben wir noch nie gemacht, weil wir vor die Toten sind. Um mich kurz steuerrechtlich abzusichern und in regendliche andere Richtungen auch. Hat dein Steuerberater wirklich gesagt, du musst diesen Vertrag erfüllen, der ja zustande gekommen ist? Nein, das ist mein Gewissen hat mir das gesagt. Und wir müssen es nicht mehr machen. Es tut mir auch wirklich leid an Moritz Burger mit dem Fuchs-Emoji, dass wir das noch nicht gemacht haben, weil das ist uncool. Und wir haben auch ein paar vergessen. Falls wir es vergessen haben und ihr habt zu viel bezahlt, gerne noch mal schreiben. Hier kommt Moritz. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, in welcher Form ich diese Nachricht hinterlassen soll, die ihr angeblich vorlesst. Ich probiere es mal hier. Sorry, an der Stelle, dass wir es da nicht gelesen haben. Ich studiere Mathematik und habe heute das Will-Rogers-Phänomen kennengelernt. Das ist nichts Kompliziertes, ein relativ einfacher, stochastischer Effekt. Das Interessanteste daran ist, dass er nach einem Gag des amerikanischen Comedians und Schauspielers Will Rogers benannt ist. Überlegt euch selber, wie ihr das unterbringt, aber ich habe dafür bezahlt. Bei Aussage von vor einem Jahr Moritz Burger. Patrick G. schreibt runter, ich weiß nicht, ob wir die Kommentare vorlesen müssen, das war nur ein Scherz, glaube ich, vor acht Monaten. Ne, das war kein Scherz, ihr sollt uns wirklich Nachrichten schicken. Ja. Okay, danke an Moritz für den Will Rogers-Effekt. Dankeschön. Danke, hast du nachgeguckt, was es ist? Okay. Ich weiß nicht, wo Steuerrecht aufhört, ehrlich gesagt.
Wo fängt es an, wo hört es auf, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Vor allem bei mir ist es immer so, ich habe immer Angst davor, die ganz grundlegenden Fragen zu stellen, weil ich immer davon ausgehe, dass man das schon wissen muss.
Und dann auch mal so eine Frage, lieber Herr Steuerberater, wo, also wie, wo verdienen Sie denn jetzt Geld? Also, ich weiß, es geht mich nichts an, aber haben Sie ein funktionierendes Geschäftsmodell? Weil Sie helfen ja anderen Leuten. Aber wo kommt, also wie verdienen Sie denn Geld? Das fragst du aber nicht wirklich. Das ist eine Scherzfrage, das ist gerade ein Bits. Nee, wirklich, 100 Prozent. Also, die kriegen da natürlich eine Gebühr. Keine Ahnung, ich weiss es nicht, aber ich stimme mir vor, wenn er sagt so, Scheiße, stimmt eigentlich, fuck ey, gut, danke, dass du uns darauf hingewiesen hast, seit Jahren denken wir uns, da kommt kein Cent rein, was ist das hier eigentlich, wir machen es gerne. Nee, nee, nee, die kriegen natürlich eine Gebühr. Aber Steuererklärung ... Steuererklärung! Auf einfache Lösung, die du kommst, genau wie damals bei GoButler, diese App von Yoko, wo man dir hinschreiben konnte, die einem dann Dinge besorgt. Zum Beispiel, ich brauche jetzt einen kleinen Büchsigen. Und dann hat er einen kleinen Büchsigen besorgt, diese App. Damit hat er geworben, dass er alles machen kann. Und da hast du auch schon die Frage gestellt, wo verdienen die denn jetzt? Ja, und Herr Tietze, wo ist denn die App jetzt? Stimmt, aber auch die haben das Prinzip, die kriegen was davon ab. Also, falls du diese Frage nochmal irgendwann stellst, versuch mal, diese kleine Eselsbrücke zu bauen. Ja, Steuererklärung. Die nehmen sich was davon. Habe ich jetzt auch in der Mitte Steuererklärung, Steuererklärung, oder wie ich es nenne, die Zeit des Jahres, wo man merkt, dass man eigentlich nur ein massiv übergewichtiger Siebenjähriger ist, der nicht die absoluten viel Taxi fährt. Und dann schicken Sie mir die Rechnung, ja, Sie haben jetzt Rechnungsnummer eins, zwei, fünf, sieben, sieben, sieben, sieben, acht, sechzehn. Und deine Steuernummer ist neun, acht, sieben, sechs, fünf, vier 7 6 5 4 3 2 1. Wo haben Sie zählen gelernt, Herr Will? Äh, ja, äh, das weiß ich nicht. Ist das nicht eine wahre Geschichte, dass du, dass deine Steuernummer auf allen Sachen, die du aufgegeben hast, dass die Default-Steuernummer ist, die im Pages-Layout zu finden ist. 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1. Wo das Finanzamt auch sagt, okay, alles klar, Leute. Ja, das musst du jetzt aber auch hier nicht erwähnen, das tut nichts zur Sache. Wo das Finanzamt einfach merkt, okay, Apple-User, einfach, okay, Trottel. Ich dachte mir, Pages, okay, krass, wo die meine Nummer nicht schnell. Ich ist so glatt, dass ich die Frage stellen muss, aber Herr Will, wohnen Sie wirklich in der Musterstrasse X? Oh, oh, äh, nee, seit letztem Jahr nicht mehr, ich bin jetzt umgezogen. Ich bin jetzt umgezogen in Musterstrasse 12. 1a. Oh, sorry. Oh, oh, oh. Spreche ich mit Herrn Mustermann? Nee. Aber es ist auch, glaube ich, jedes Gespräch, also wenn du mich so durch die Fußgänger zu laufen lässt, hört, oh, oh, dann telefoniere ich mir mit meinem Steuerberater. Das ist das Geräusch, was ich mache. Ach so. Ach so, nee, das wusste ich nicht. Oder alternativ, dann muss ich mal gucken. Funfact, ich finde nichts, wenn ich dann noch mal gucke. Tatsächlich, es wurde jetzt gerade das Jugendwort des Jahres gekürt. Wir können ja auch eine Phrase machen, die Phrase des Jahres. Das Podcast-UFO-Phrase des Jahres. Und meine Phrase des Jahres, die ich, glaube ich, dieses Jahr so häufig wie nie und so gerne wie nie eingesetzt habe, war, ja, ich gucke mal. Ja, muss ich mal gucken. Ja, muss ich mal gucken. Ja, oder vor allem, das gibt es ja auch in verschiedenen Varianten so, ja, dann müssen wir mal gucken. Also wir, also dann müssen wir mal gucken. Dann müssen wir mal schauen, dann müssen wir mal gucken. Und diese Phrase bedeutet, ich möchte das Gespräch jetzt so schnell es geht beenden, ohne irgendwelche Konsequenzen daraus für mich abfallen. Ja, müssen wir mal gucken. Ciao. Einfach. Und ich geniesse diesen Satz so sehr, weil es ist herrlich, weil jeder denkt, ah, okay. Aber nee. Nee, nicht okay. Gegenteil davon. Nee, es wird immer schlimmer. Sie müssen bitte bis zum vierten achten ihren Stromzähler abgelesen haben. Ja, genau. Okay, dann müssen wir mal gucken. Okay, tschüss. Und dann denke ich, dieses Problem ist noch offen. Aber es ist nicht offen, es ist sehr konkret und es ist sehr konkret bedrohlich. Ich habe mir eine Waschmaschine bestellt, jetzt weil ich satt bin mit dem Waschsalon.
Was?
Du hast es satt, oder was?
Was bist du? Du bist satt?
Weil ich es satt bin, das zu tun.
Achso, es satt bist.
Ja.
Ja. Was? Du hast es satt, oder was? Was bist du? Du bist satt? Weil ich
es satt bin, das zu tun. Ach so, es satt bist.
Ja. Kann man das sagen?
Ja. Ist das erlaubt?
Podcast-Polizei will. Ja, ich hab's nicht
richtig verstanden, weil du zu 40 Meter von mir
entfernt sitzt. Ja, der Raum ist weird.
Sehr schmal, aber sehr lang.
Ich hab eine Waschmaschine
bestellt, aus Versehen zur
falschen Adresse, mit aber mit Installation. Heißt. So an der Hauswand, außen montiert. Heißt, fast. Es war wenige Minuten davon entfernt, war ich von diesem Problem, dass meine Waschmaschine in meiner Firma installiert wurde. Und das war schon ein komisches Problem. Und dann, also, das sind ganz viele Fragen, habe ich auch zu dieser ganzen Sache. Deswegen wollte ich es diese Woche noch nicht erzählen, weil ich muss dann noch ein bisschen recherchieren und aufräumen. Die Firma Amazon Logistics hat das übernommen. Dann habe ich den Kundenservice angerufen und gesagt, die werden das wahrscheinlich zum falschen Ort liefern. Dann haben die gesagt, ja, wir haben nichts, wir sind bei Amazon angerufen. Und ich so, ja, genau, schweigen. Ja, ja, wir sind nicht Amazon Logistics, wir haben nichts mit denen zu tun. Da muss ich bei Amazon Logistics anrufen. Und die haben dann irgendwie gemeint, ja, wir kümmern uns drum.
Haben sie natürlich nicht, deswegen wurde dann die Waschmaschine voran installiert.
Und dann hat jemand gesagt, ja, wir können es einfach morgen vorbeibringen. Änden sie mich einfach bei WhatsApp? Da hat irgendwer von Amazon Logistics, hat jetzt meine Handynummer und ich schreibe jetzt mit dem bei WhatsApp, wann er mir meine Waschmaschine liefert, ich musste die aber schon stornieren. Heisst, er ruft mich an, abends, privat, im Hintergrund waren Kinder am Schreien, ob ich aber morgen diese Waschmaschine zu mir liefern soll und warum ich das storniert hätte. Das muss ich ja machen, weil das war ein Problem, weil sie werden ja fast woanders installiert, da habe ich die ja vorher lieber mal storniert. Da hat mir Amazon geraten, das einfach zu stornieren, die Erstattung zu nehmen und die Waschmaschine zurückschicken zu lassen. Aber das Bild von diesem Menschen bei Amazon, sein Profilbild, ist seine Tochter, so eine kleine Tochter, die spielt. Und er hat das fotografiert, diese kleine Tochter, die beim Spielen. Und immer wenn ich mit diesem Amazon-Typen schreibe, den ich abwimmeln will, weil er meine Waschmaschine zurückschicken will, sehe ich halt seine kleine Tochter und denke mir, ich würde ihm echt gern diesen Job ermöglichen, mir jetzt die Waffmaschine aufzubauen. Und dann würde ich ihm noch ein bisschen Trinker geben für seine Tochter, kaufen sie ihrer Tochter eine gemischte Tüte. Aber das ist doch der Punkt, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt wird es unseriös. Immer wenn jemand sagt, add mich bei WhatsApp, sage ich, nope, müssen wir echt mal ein bisschen gucken, aber das mache ich nicht. Ja, das passiert häufiger. Ich würde nie jemanden bei WhatsApp-App in. Ich glaube, ich bin der Mensch, ich habe die wenigsten Emojis. Und ich kriege am allerhäufigsten dieses Fragezeichen, wenn jemand dir ein Emoji schickt, das du selber nicht hast in deinem Betriebssystem. Das Kasten-Ding. Diesen Kasten mit dem Fragezeichen, wie bei Super Mario. Die Leute verstehen einfach nicht, was du denen sagen willst. Deswegen schicken sie das Kasten-Emoji. das Fragezeichen-Emoji. Ich glaube nicht, aber ich kriege teilweise wirklich ganze Reihen von Emojis, wo jeder zweite dieses Fragezeichen ist und ich teilweise wirklich Schwierigkeiten habe zu kommunizieren. Du mit deiner strengen Kein-Update-Philosophie. Nee, ich habe auch die strengen Kein-Update-Philosophie. Ja, aber die macht keinen Sinn. An solchen Stellen, du kannst nicht, nein, du kannst nicht diese Kein-Update-Philosophie haben, aber gleichzeitig dich darüber aufregen, dass es nicht geupdate ist. Nein, ich regne mich nicht drüber auf, ich sage nur, dass man bitte keine Emotis verwendet, wenn man überschreiben soll, und vor allem bitte nicht irgendwie den Taco oder so. Ein sehr konkreter Wunsch an unsere Hörer. Irgendwie, ja, ich gehe davon aus, dass mich alle, wollen wir eigentlich eine WhatsApp-Gruppe gründen, eine Podcast-Suche-WhatsApp-Gruppe? Ja, aber haben alle unsere Nummer, oder nicht? Kann man da nicht die Nummer unterdrücken? Ich weiß nicht, wie will das nicht, dass alle unsere Privatnummer haben. Wäre das denn so schlimm, wenn die unsere Nummer... Naja, kann man nicht... Kann man bei WhatsApp nicht die Nummer unterdrücken? Ja, ich würde gerne WhatsApp rüber machen. Die Podcasts, weil da können alle User halt einfach in die Gruppe, und dann können die irgendwie Sachen schicken. Aber ich weiss, was ich lustig finde, weil ich habe, also in unserem Chatverlauf, dem zwischen uns beiden, wir haben nichts zu verbergen, wir haben nichts zu verstecken.
Wollen wir alle unsere Kommunikation, die wir beide haben miteinander, einfach in diese öffentliche WhatsApp-Gruppe legen?
Vor allem, wir kommunizieren ja wirklich zu 100 Prozent über das Podcast-Ufo.
Nicht mal so ein, ey, ich habe jetzt echt Stress irgendwie mit der Claudia, ich weiß nicht, sie ruft mich nicht mehr an und überhaupt existiert oder ob ich mit einem Hologramm gesprochen habe.
Nichts, einfach nur Podcast-Ufobusiness. Können wir machen. Nicht Privates, nicht mal alles Gute zum Geburtstag. Aber kann man bei einer WhatsApp-Gruppe eigentlich die Nummer unterdrücken? Wir werden das testen, wir werden die große Das-Podcast-Uf-WhatsApp-Gruppe starten und dann könnt ihr dann irgendwie heiße Themenvorschläge machen oder Gags, wo ihr euch miteinander
sprechen könnt. Könnt ihr euch kennenlernen?
Und ich würde auch mal gerne, das ist auf meiner Liste für 2019,
hätte ich mal gerne eine Live-Folge Podcast-Ufo.
Irgendwo machen wir, also
wo Leute anrufen können.
Nicht das, was wir die ganze Zeit schon machen.
Es tut mir leid, dass ich das sagen muss.
Ja? Leute anrufen können?
Wir können live während, stimmt, wir können WhatsApp Sprachnachrichten dann spielen.
Ja, oder wir machen einfach mal bei Twitch oder so.
Oder keine Ahnung, wie das gehen soll.
Kurze Sache noch, Dänemark und UFOs scheint ein bekanntes Problem zu sein.
Ja.
Es kam noch eine Mail, noch jemand hat ein UFO in Dänemark gesehen.
Ja, ein UFO oder wie es in Expertenkreisen genannt wird, eine Drohne. Es ist eine Drohne. Nee, das ist ein UFO, wo GoPro draufsteht. Nein, die sind nicht vom Planeten GoPro, das ist einfach eine Drohne. Was ist das?
Beim FBI muss es auch so zwei Praktis geben, die den ganzen Tag am Telefon hängen und sagen, nee, es ist eine Drohne.
Es ist eine Drohne.
Ach, wie lustig das wäre. Nee, es ist eine Drohne. Ist notiert, aber es ist eine Drohne.
Ich glaube, Horrorfilme und Comedies sind, glaube ich, sehr nah beieinander.
Fällt mir gerade auf. Weil das Gruseligste und Lustigste, was ich mir gerade vorstellen konnte, ist, schau mal vor, du besuchst einen Maya-Tempel und dann siehst du da so eine Höhlenmalerei, so eine Steinschnitzerei und dann siehst du jemanden mit einer GoPro, offensichtlich mit einer GoPro auf der Stirn. Ja. So, wie man das Tier aufschmallt. Oder so ein Duckface. So ein Selfie-Duckface machend. Aber wie gruselig das wäre. Das wäre gr gruselig. Wenn da jemand offensichtlich was nichts anderes sagt, wo auch GoPro klein draufsteht, Hero4. Aber hast du nicht das erzählt mit dem Kölner Dom, dass da Steinmetze auch Leute mit Handys reinmachen? Nee, habe ich nicht erzählt. Irgendjemand hat mir das erzählt, weil tatsächlich ja auch moderne Steinmetze am Kölner Dom arbeiten. Also jetzt nicht irgendwie oben oder irgendwie sowas. Und anscheinend ist es so gängig unter Steinmetzen, dass man sozusagen eine eigene kleine Figur irgendwo reinmeißelt. Und das machen moderne Steinmetzer natürlich auch. Und die machen das, dass ich mit einem Handy oder so. Das heißt, im Kölner Dom sind Figuren mit Handys abgebildet. Auch der Jesus hinten ist auch weird. Der Jesus, der Fotos macht von den Leuten, die zugucken bei der Messe. Und Super Mario, oder bin ich komplett bescheuert? Der Dabbing-Jesus. Vielleicht verwechselst du auch massiv gerade. Ne, ne, ich glaube, es stimmt schon so. Ich halte es mal so fest. Wenn der Einzige, das ist eine sehr moderne Kirche, der Kölner-Dom. Jesus dabbt. Ja, aber in tausend Jahren, Historiker graben das aus und denken sich, what? Was macht Jesus da? Warum, das ist doch... Wo steckt er den Arm? Ist das nicht das, was Justin Bould immer gemacht hat, sagen dann die Historiker. Nazi war jetzt in dieser Partei drin, oder was? Ich verstehe gar nichts mehr. Machen wir eigentlich zwei Stunden Folgen mittlerweile? Das dauert immer lange. Ja, weil wir die erste Hälfte immer rausschneiden müssen, weil du immer irgendwelche wilden Theorien aufstellst und am Ende sagst, nee, schneid's raus. Nee, vielleicht war mir wieder Holocaust geleugnet. Ich habe übrigens überlegt, also es kommen sehr viele Nachrichten mit dem Gemälde. Es kommen sehr viele Nachrichten, ob ich das mal zeigen kann. Ist es schon geleakt auf Pupedia. Es ist noch nicht geleakt, aber die Person, der ich es geschickt habe, hat die Folge gehört und hat gesagt, bin ich die Person, der es als einziger geschickt ist? Oh. Ja. Das heißt,. Das heißt, diese Person weiß jetzt sogar, dass sie die Person mit der Verantwortung ist. So viel Druck. Das ist zu viel Druck auf einer Person. Das ist diese Psychotricks. Also, ich habe mir überlegt, ich verrate euch den Namen der Künstlerin. Ja, das ist eine Künstlerin. Und zwar finde ich es nämlich lustig, weil die Vorstellung, dass ich in Kunst investiert habe, ich habe ja eh schon die Hälfte des Schätzpreises bezahlt. Ich finde es lustig, wenn die Künstlerin einfach massiv durch die Decke gehen würde. Die ist nämlich schon tot mittlerweile, das ist schon gut. Ist das jetzt auch wieder so eine Art Finanztipp von dir, wo alle anderen Finanztipps wiegegeben hast, sind nach unten gegangen? Das ist ein Finanztrick für mich, weil ich will jetzt, dass ihr, wenn ihr mal, also die Künstlerin heißt Ulrike Roth. Ulrike Roth. O-T-H? R-O-T-H, und ich möchte gerne, dass ihr, wenn ihr mal eine Führung macht, im Museum of Modern Art oder so, und dann wird euch ein Bild gezeigt, dass ihr alle sowas sagen könnt wie, ja, ist jetzt keine Ulrike Roth, aber gut, und weiter geht, einfach, dass alle Kunsthistoriker und Kunsthändler, kurz aufheuchen, mit was, und Ulrike Roth auf dem Schirm haben. Oder generell, wenn ihr gefragt werdet, was ist euer Lieblingskünstler, sagt ihr natürlich Ulrike Roth. Also gut, ich mag sie alle. Ich mag Van Gogh, Dali, großer Fan, Ulrike Roth natürlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich es der Reihenfolge genannt habe. Aber das ist die ganze Zeit immer, also wenn ihr, ich finde es wahnsinnig lustig, weil ich glaube, wir haben eine Masse erreicht an Hörern, die was erreichen können. Die gesellschaftlich was verändern können. Genau, wir könnten was Gutes erreichen, wie wir unterjochen Nazis. Nein, wir machen das. Wir machen Stefan reich. Wir machen mich reich und Ulrike Roth gross. Post whom. Oder am besten einfach jetzt alle Bilder von ihr aufkaufen, allein Verknappung macht ja schon was. Nee, die will ich ja haben. Du willst alle Bilder haben. Das lasst ja immer von ihr. Wie viele Bilder hast du von ihr? Eins habe ich bislang nur. Aber wenn die immer so riesig sind, hat die auch irgendwie so kleine Figuren geschnitzt oder so, die man irgendwie handlicher ein bisschen handhaben kann. Das ist Souvenirgrösser halt. Nee, ich verrate noch nicht, wie das Kunstwerk heißt, könnte man aber jetzt finden, theoretisch glaube ich. Die hat nicht so viel gemalt. Die ist noch nicht so bekannt, ich fände es wahnsinnig lustig, wenn wir die einfach riesig machen und überall an jeder Ecke sagen, ja ist keine Ulrike Roth oder wow, Ulrike Roth, jetzt schön ein Ulrike Roth Gemälde angucken. Jetzt so zwei Stunden ... Jedes Handy hat ein Ulrike Roth-Gemälde als Hintergrund, einfach in jeder kunstwissenschaftlichen Analyse.
Gibt's irgendeinen Kunststudenten da draußen, der sagt,
mir ist eh alles scheissegal, ich studiere Kunst,
ich schreib meine Doktorarbeit über Ulrike Roth. Oder so ein schön Kunstfälscherskandal, wo jemand Ulrike Roth malt. Ja! Und ich dann sagen kann, er ist sogar kein Ulrike Roth. Das stimmt. Und dann der Kunstmach aufhört. Wer ist denn, wer wer überhaupt diese Ulrike Roth? Genau, oder dass irgendwie eines, wo man dachte, es ist von Monet oder so, ist eigentlich von Ulrike Roth. Ja, einfach mal penetrant Ulrike Roth featuren. Ich finde das wahnsinnig lustig.
Wir legen auch einen Twitter-Account an, Ulrike Roth.
Nee, sie ist schon tot. Aber vielleicht einen Wikipedia-Eintrag. Also einfach mal wahnsinnig viel Ulrike Roth.
Big Ulrike Roth, big again. 2019 ist das Ulrike Roth.
Ich glaube, die war nie big.
Sie braucht eine Strasse, das ist unser Ziel.
Oh ja, oh fuck ja.
Sie braucht eine Strasse, sie braucht ein eigenes Emoji. Sie braucht eine Schule, die Ulrike Rothschule. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Sie braucht irgendwie so einen statistischen Effekt, der Ulrike Roth-Effekt oder irgendwie so ein Quatsch, irgendwas Wissenschaftliches. Irgendwas farbwissenschaftliches. wissenschaftlich und eigentlich müsste die aktuelle kunsthistorische Epoche nach ihr benannt werden genau also irgendwie Romantik Klassik
Prä-Rot, Post-Rot, Hellrot, ja, je nachdem. Es müsste eine Farbe nach ihr benannt werden. Das wäre eigentlich so das Maximum, ja, das wäre grossartig. Na gut, vielleicht schaffen wir es nicht, aber naja. Und vielleicht so eine Wellenlänge oder irgendwie ein, ich scheiß drauf, egal, irgendwas kriegen wir schon hin. Das wäre grossartig, ja, Ulrike Roth. Und ihr wisst auch, wie die Folge heissen wird, denn das wird eine der grössten Künstlerinnen der Neuzeit, ob sie's will oder nicht. Ulrike Roth heißt die Folge. Ja, genau, diese Entscheidung hat sie getroffen, indem sie so fantastische Kunstwerke gemalt hat. Aber warte mal, dann denken alle, Ulrike Roth ist zu Gast in der Folge, weil Folgen haben ja immer nur Namen. Nee, wir können das auch nicht Ulrike Roth nennen., ist das Copyright oder was? Die Folge mit Luke Mockridge hieß Luke Mockridge. Wenn die Folge jetzt Ulrike Roth heißt, dann denken alle Leute, Ulrike Roth ist zu Gast. Picasso, Deconing, Monet, Flaubert, Roth, Tod. Dir fällt schon was ein, wenn du die Folge hochlädst. Bin ich mir sehr sicher. Gut, dann haut rein. Oh, ist die nächste Folge schon? Ne, wir haben noch eine Folge jetzt normal und dann ist Köln. Nächste Woche bin ich da. Bitte wo bin ich denn? Äh, bis jetzt nächste Woche bin ich in München. Nächste Woche bin ich in München. Vielleicht bin ich ja im Biergarten. Du bist im Miengarten. So schön im englischen Garten bin ich unterwegs. Es gibt Groscheligsbienen, weil jeder Bierbrauer versucht, ein guten Bier zu brauen. Ja, wird schon. Ich kann ja anrufen aus München und dann mache ich so eine To-Go-Folge. Ich bin unterwegs und du bist im Studio. Wie lange bist du in München? Du bist nicht die ganze Woche in München. Von Samstag bis Mittwoch und dann bin ich wieder in Hamburg. Sabis Mi. Sami und dann ab Do bin ich wieder in H. Ach so. Naja, kriegen wir hin. Vielleicht machen wir eine Call-In-Folge oder eine Pocket-Folge.
Machen wir eine Call-In-Folge, ähm, genau.
Vielen Dank nochmal an Waldi oder Wolli für das Intro, es war fantastisch.
Vielen Dank an Wolli.
Haut rein, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ulrich Rothfeaturen, macht's gut, ciao, ciao.